cuando hablamos de los órganos
endocrinos y las glándulas endocrinas y
de hormonas volando alrededor del cuerpo
es bastante fácil desarrollar una imagen
mental de este proceso que pasa de
manera bastante azarosa podemos imaginar
a las hormonas fluyendo por todo el
cuerpo arrojadas a su voluntad y a todas
partes si piensas en los efectos de las
glándulas endocrinas como en las
glándulas suprarrenales como las
hormonas de lucha o william es muy
importante que los efectos que son
estimulados por esas hormonas sean
controlados pues nuestro cuerpo es muy
sensible a esos efectos y resulta que la
concentración de hormonas en nuestra
sangre está bastante bien controlada en
todo momento una de las formas en las
que se controla es a través de esta idea
de metabolismo
y también de expresión así que por cada
hormona que llega a su receptor miles
más son barridas y eliminadas por el
cuerpo y una manera de eliminarlas es a
través del hígado el cual metaboliza las
hormonas extras y las convierte en bilis
que finalmente se excreta en el sistema
digestivo otro órgano es el riñón
tenemos dos de ellos los riñones filtran
la sangre todo el tiempo eliminando
productos de desechos de la sangre a
través de la orina algunas hormonas se
descomponen en la sangre después fluyen
al hígado o a los riñones e incluso
algunas veces las sudamos
pero la idea que quiero resaltar es que
por todas las hormonas que llegan a los
receptores muchas más se barren y se
eliminan del cuerpo otra forma de
controlar la concentración de hormonas
en el cuerpo es por medio de circuitos
de retroalimentación
y la mayoría de los circuitos de
retroalimentación son los que
consideramos circuitos de
retroalimentación negativa la idea
detrás los circuitos de realimentación
negativa es que las condiciones
resultantes de la acción hormonal
suprimen la liberación adicional de esas
hormonas y tal vez la idea sea un poco
confusa así que vamos a dibujar un
ejemplo por aquí tenemos al hipotálamo
vamos a señalarlo y escribiremos su
nombre por acá hipotálamo y el
hipotálamo libera la hormona liberadora
de tirotropina tr y la libera y baja a
la glándula pituitaria que escribiremos
por acá la glándula pituitaria como
respuesta a la tr
la glándula pituitaria libera la hormona
estimulante de la tiroides
s h
la t s h baja a la glándula tiroides que
está por acá déjame escribirlo la
glándula tiroides y esta libera sus
hormonas la hormona t3 o trillado tironi
na y tiroxina estas hormonas tiroideas
viajan a través del cuerpo en busca de
receptores para regular el metabolismo
este es uno de los trabajos principales
de la glándula tiroides
aquí es donde esta idea se vuelve genial
porque algunos de los receptores se
localizan en la pituitaria y en el
hipotálamo ya medida que las hormonas
tiroideas llegan a la pituitaria y el
hipotálamo mandan la señal al hipotálamo
ya la pituitaria de parar la producción
de sus hormonas
el hipotálamo y la glándula pituitaria
captan que hay suficientes hormonas
tiroideas en la sangre y que no
necesitan producir más esta es una forma
importante de controlar los niveles de
hormonas tiroideas en el cuerpo y tal
vez podamos decir oye esto suena un poco
redundante es decir si las hormonas
tiroideas pueden apagar el hipotálamo y
esteban antes que la glándula pituitaria
entonces porque la glándula pituitaria
tiene que tener esos receptores pero la
redundancia es sólo un reflejo de qué
tan importantes son el control de
retroalimentación y la concentración de
hormonas por lo tanto esperamos que se
entienda que los niveles de hormonas en
el cuerpo no son casuales ni
desordenados
que la concentración
importante